Jedidiah be hello how are you I know
well how you doing
sit down welcome welcome Jedediah bila
my old friend did you know that he was
somehow involved with Michael Cohen no
did I know oh yeah
what are you saying you saw that coming
so I saw that coming just cause coming
from Fox News Oh on the paper yeah yeah
no yeah I like Sean a lot I like him cuz
he stuck up for Opie and Anthony you
know any any yeah he's always been good
to me too so that's how I judge people
how they treat me I don't did you hear
about yeah no I heard he was he was it
he was cool when I met him when Anthony
got fired that day you know who texted
me a concern Sean he did and he's like
hey let me give me his number I want to
reach out to him right you know and see
what the [ __ ] he's doing you know he's
actually yeah he is good like that yeah
it's funny if you do if you do like nice
things for people they just it's like
you you're locked in for life sometimes
yeah I mean sometimes other people you
do nice things forever and they'll still
[ __ ] on doesn't matter yeah we prefer it
I don't know let me see let me the
headphones you struggling with all these
years in media and the headphones or it
happens yeah try that I'm the last
professional broadcast an exceptionally
small like it's disturbing we had that
on the prep sheet but we took it off
very soon known for her small head
really small hat and her so how's your
how's how's life I mean I got married a
wheel in the air we are yeah really yeah
that time are you serious yeah is and be
adjusting your microphone yeah
did Roly tell you that will you come in
are you serious you didn't say anything
bad
oh my god Wow tiny head yeah we're gonna
know now I do have an exceptionally
small I didn't know I was on the air you
are your honor
boy again you're lucky that I didn't say
oh wow oh you're lucky that you didn't
say yeah got
come for you right right next to me with
that girly hair when it came right for
you Joe has warned how's that by the way
guess when you come on on this show they
don't warn you that you're on the air
because they hope you'll say something
really scans rollers will tell you you
know I hear we told not to with you like
that he talks I said just yet don't tell
her she's on the air we'll see how long
we can keep her going alright yeah that
was the that was the plan now I know I'm
Mike so Mike yeah also when we like
shove these big things yeah faces we go
like they might be Pam what are you what
are you doing with yourself right so I
just finished a book which is amazing
yes it's gonna change the world this
comes out in October it's it's like the
best book ever but mostly because it's
about me no it does have a lot of my
personal stories in it I can't talk
about it too much because I don't have
I'm not allowed to release the title or
anything it's like yeah it's very it's
like it's got to be times I'm like I'm
going on air why not like it's no now's
the time right no no no but it's amazing
it's gonna so basically I've been
writing it I've been writing it I'm it's
done now just shot the cover got married
he's here he's sitting on the floor he's
like don't you dare come at me with that
microphone he's camera shy how did you
meet a Quay we met at the gym Wow
actually I'm all for to 70 at the gym
I've never ever met anybody terrible how
long how long did you mean it how long
ago did you meet him uh two and a half
years we were talking about him when you
first started dating him when you came
on and did the night show did we and it
was like it was like a new relationship
oh my god can you marry them and I
married him congratulation and he's here
so shut up soon how did it start you
were friends first right now approached
you I thought I actually thought can I
say it I thought he was gay I actually I
did I chose every woman who dates me I
thought it was funny he was like oh you
know some guy just hit on me am i doing
something to make them want to do that
and I thought oh he's trying to pick up
guys let me help him out I'm great like
I have a ton of gay friends I know
exactly what to tell you
he wasn't he had just made a really
weird kind of flirtatious like it was
him trying to be flirty but right it
didn't happen so everybody wants the gay
best friends that was like I found him
at the gym turns out now I married him
when did you realize he wasn't gay like
when did you realize that was a day you
know the first time we hung out we I
thought we were hanging out as friends
and we had a burger and he was like
throwing little cute like he's not he's
he's like a little goofy which I love
and he doesn't flirt exceptionally well
which is why I chose him because I like
if you know anything about me I like
that kind of like goofy like Peter
Parker a little lost like and he was
trying to flirt and I was like oh wow
he's not gay and he likes me and he's a
little goofy so it hit that's when it
and we did a bunch of walks together it
was very romantic I like long walks and
slow Sicilian Michael Corleone that is
gonna be covered in your book oh yeah I
talked about that I talked about a an
ex-boyfriend I talked about yeah it gets
it gets embarrassing I mean I the book
is is is indeed it's it's a lot of
personal stuff people it's just amazing
because I believe like two years ago
when we talked you were talking about
how you wanted to write a book yeah
you're talking about first meeting this
guy in the gym look this is this is
called you'd make a checklist and you
just go right and in the meantime you
were on the view for a while I became
this big celebrity person but I'm still
notice how I came back to where it
counts see same person what happened on
the view did you leave voluntarily are
they did they ask you to leave uh I you
know I knew you were gonna get to the
juice of everybody in this building um I
I didn't leave voluntarily I had just
signed I have to be very careful about
how this is all said but ya know I I had
signed for a new season I think about
like a week and a half before it was
super excited in fact they released all
this really cool merchandise with all of
our faces on it and I was like I just
put a post up like oh my god I've never
been on a bug before then my mom was
like she still has the mug and it's like
a really tender spot
no I I don't know like I I don't know
what happened how did they let you know
um Wow
enjoy the mug uh I got a phone call I
actually just got a phone call and was
kind of told but I didn't I can't really
talk about this I'm not supposed to
really get into it but the only thing I
can say is I don't know like I don't
everybody says well why did you leave
and I'm like I don't have an answer for
you I wish I could explain I have a
group one thing I will say I have a
great relationship with everybody on
that set I get along with every single
host two of them were at my wedding I
mean I communicate with all of them
sunny and Sarah actually I'm sorry sunny
and Sarah were invited to the wedding we
were very tight Sarah couldn't come
sunny was at the wedding with her
husband just close with what be like joy
just texted her a couple of weeks ago
got along with all the producers never
had a fight there's no drum everybody
was right at the view I had zero drama
love them all to pieces
even the producers like love them well I
had no beef is it inert but any type of
phone call like that we've all got them
in our lives is like yeah yeah look we
love you
we're fans but right now they just the
direction they want to go in as always
and my manager false word every time
he's like give them fans
John shut up no one's a fan and then
goes you gotta go but exactly sometimes
you know ya know I mean the one thing I
will say that was really nice was that I
got an outpouring from fans and a lot of
them were from liberals like I you know
I'm this libertarian conservative kind
of warrior and a lot of the liberals
were like we're really gonna miss you
like what happened and the thing that I
was just most upset about is I didn't
want people to think that the fans that
I just got up one day left and left
because I didn't want the tough debate
or I didn't wanna I love that stuff you
know and I love those women and I you
know I root for them at home all the
time I'm talk talk to sunny all the time
I'm like go girl you know I have no beef
I'll watch it to be occasionally I will
yeah if sunny tells me there's gonna be
something cool on I'll turn it on and
I'll watch her and I occasionally will
flip it on were you there when Obama or
trumpetear I was not there was I was
there for Hillary Clinton oh that was my
last my last interview that I
dirty like that day when you're going to
a lot a lot you you're like you feel
like you you never feel less important
because you realize what it looks like
when you're there versus when she's
there right Wow nobody cares about me at
all but is that a nerve-wracking day
especially for you because like your
role on the show is to be the contrarian
to her and you're the only one like
nobody's gonna be on your side but at
the same time you can't say anything
that's like disrespectful because yeah
guess booking yeah it's a challenge I
mean it was definitely I had to kind of
figure I wanted to ask her about her
emails and that's the question I didn't
get out I asked her a portent question I
thought about how I felt that she was a
little tone deaf I felt that the book
read tone deaf and she really wasn't
acknowledging why she lost I don't think
she loved that question it's probably
not tone deaf is never good yeah and
then I said it and then of course when I
left you know I didn't know that I
wasn't gonna be there the next week and
everybody was writing like oh did she
have fired because of Hillary Clinton
and I was like what that was the story
that I was like I have no idea like I
don't think so I mean I I didn't get any
you know certainly didn't get any
scolding for that would make you feel
good though to know like okay well if
I'm gonna get fired at least it's
because Hillary Clinton was so offended
by my question I always like imagine
what would have happened to me if I
asked about the emails no but it's not
your first time meteor yes that was my
first time meeting so when you're when
you're on the show and she's being
brought in and she's obviously running
for president there's a huge amount of
security what's the process of meeting
her before this show do they does
everybody kind of get to say hello first
or you only meet her on set you can go
up she was on the second floor so all of
our makeup rooms were on the first floor
she was on the second floor and you were
able to go up and say hello I I didn't
do that just because there it was like a
ton of people it was like crazy so I
don't I think I don't think I'll be
there were a few of us that didn't do
that maybe joy might have gone up I'm
not sure I think joy has a photo of like
Hillary's reading Joy's book and Joy's
reading Hillary's book I'm not sure if
they took that before or whatever but I
didn't go up and I the first time I saw
her was backstage and I was very polite
to her she was very polite to me and
it's kind of it's kind of bizarre though
because I spent a really long time sort
of picking on her sure and I'm sure
she knew it I mean I was digging in on
those emails like nobody there used to
it crazy right they were pretty used to
that [ __ ] it was different though like
Hillary cuz we had Joe Biden on as well
and Joe Biden was awesome Joe Biden like
leaned in and was like you know I'm a
big fan but he was like you know he was
he was like I'm a big fan he did say
that not in the creepy way you said it
but it was different he was a very warm
kind of personable Hillary was kind of
standoffish I find it hard to kind of
that's why why she lost people didn't
feel connected to her did you Bernie
Sanders on the show we had Bernie on yes
I remember you had a thing for Bernie
Sanders I do like I do like him I too I
think he's so sweet and he's like a
little grumpy and I like a little grumpy
guy you know I did and I think we had a
conversation a time about how I used to
think I was gonna man I actually thought
I was gonna marry like an 80 year old no
no joke my daddy my dad used to be like
just make sure he's younger than me and
they thought I was gonna go to the
old-age home and like I used to love
even when I was in grad school well when
I was in college I dated a much older
guy he was like 35 and I was 19 so it
started Wow good for you what did you
like about that was it the maturity
level like a bullshitter yeah because I
wasn't a drinker I wasn't a partier I
was kind of an old soul I grew up by
like 10 I was like an adult so I wanted
to be I was always hung around adults I
was an only child and I hung out my mom
and her friends and I just liked being
around mature people
I'm good grad school I remember I took a
class and I was like mom this teacher so
cute and she looked at the picture she's
like he's gotta be 65 years old and I
was like and your point is what
so Barney was like you know just my type
right and then I go and marry like 26
year old so go figure you married
somebody well yeah what are you trying
to say how do you know I'm not 26 I was
gonna say the same age
no you go I remembered he was younger
because we teased you a lot about you
you did but you married him so I was
wrong so I was wrong yeah I was do you
uh when you find out that you're not any
of you anymore
yeah at first you go into a panic
because like you were like going up up
up up up right you go from Fox News it's
kind of this giant leap onto the view
and
everybody's talking about you and you
maybe we're not ready to figure out
what's next yeah I guess I wasn't
prepared but I was honestly I was I was
a little sad at first just because I
loved I've never you know I had never
been in a place that I worked where I
became really friendly with the people
and those were like that was like my
family right
so I genuinely felt a little bit of
sadness and then I started of course as
everyone does you're like what did I do
you know what what happened I didn't
know what happened I still don't know
what happened I don't have an answer so
I don't know what it was or what
happened and then I and then I panicked
because I was like wow every show on
earth just started for the season where
am I gonna work right this is a terrible
time for this to happen but I was
getting married in February and I had
this book that I was excited about
luckily in process and the second that
happened I got swarmed by a bunch of
people that were like hey you want to do
this meeting or you want to come here
and I was like okay I'm gonna be fine
were you were you worried though that
when you told him he was gonna go I
wanted to marry someone from the view
over no actually he liked one thing
that's really good about him is that he
doesn't he doesn't care about any of the
celebrities they all really at all and
he's not from this world at all he's you
know he works in now he works in
publishing at the time he was a tech guy
and he's just he's a very like
down-to-earth so I was that was my
saving grace like him and my and my
parents who my mom's hilarious and would
just make tons of jokes about it how
long before you supposed to go on did
that actually happen before I was
supposed to go like how long before
you're supposed to start filming again
did that happen we had already started
the season actually um oh yeah so I did
I did one full year I had actually
tested for the show a bunch the year
prior which was I guess before I got
hired so I did a bunch of shows which
was a great time but I wasn't officially
a part of the team and then I joined for
the 20th season and then we started
season 21 I think I did like a week and
a half so I had signed on like I had
read so I I don't know I thought that
was gonna be my life you know you always
I always look on in television in terms
of like a year you never know what's
gonna happen after a year but I just
so I think it was like maybe like a week
and a half in a week and a half into a
new season get the phone call yeah
nothing happened no I had no drama do
they want you to go after Hillary harder
do you think or not did you have to hurt
- no I got I don't know I didn't hear
and I'm when I tell you I don't know
like I'll it I had no issue no I never
got into a fight at that right not one
it was so funny like people were like
writing of course every tabloid writes
everything and they wrote like Oh her
hair and makeup people and I'm like are
you kidding me like my my hair girl did
my wedding does every appear she's not
here today because she couldn't she
lives in Connecticut and she couldn't so
I have someone amazing person filling in
but I had like my makeup artist came
with me I did a lifetime special I I
last year interviewed Abby Lee Miller
but she went to jail the Dance Moms
teacher yeah who's that
um she's on Dance Moms she's like the
teacher the really controversial me
she's everybody thinks she's me and
she's really not but I inserted why is
she in jail for Young Money stuff no hit
a bunch of money and I did the interview
and I brought my makeup artist from the
view with me because I love and adore
Karen but I read that you guys didn't
get along I try read that there was
hostile like so it's funny you know
that's the way I read you threw hot
coffee on her exit she was bringing in
pictures of Kim Kardashian and Tang I
want to look like her and I'm like no
that's what we do in TV we're like hey
this makeup can we do this today like
that's the whole that was the hardest
part for me I think is just reading that
was the first time I ever read about
read stuff about me that was totally
wrong and I knew you can't say anything
cuz you're like what am I gonna say I
mean it's ridiculous this is all fake
this is all fake news what's it been
like in that whole process no no because
I mean your profile has kind of stayed
pretty high after the view yeah but like
it went way up like you yeah you were
known you know you run Fox and you're
doing stuff here and there and then once
you get on network television it's like
your profile is on another level what
was it like for you dealing with the
fact that like people in large numbers
know who you are and yeah they're about
what you say negative and positive I
think it was I I don't think I ever
really thought about it like that
because I always think of myself as a
very regular girl from Staten Island
with an opinion and I just I never feel
like a celebrity or
like a big I just feel like this is my
this is what I do
you know I show up I give my opinion the
one thing I will say is that people you
do know you read about yourself in ways
like I remember posting like a picture
of myself
the weekend we got engaged in a bikini
and it was like on the Daily Mail and
I'm like who cares like about me at all
like no one ever cared at that level so
I think you're not used to that and then
of course you know the speculation about
all why'd she leave this or why and an
awareness that whatever job you do take
is gonna be a story
everything I do becomes kind of a story
totally and it's like you don't really
ever feel like why you're like you don't
get it you don't really understand what
that is doing any find yourself early
than anybody else I just of watching
what you say like you you get good Oh
higher it goes do you get more cautious
not really I mean that's probably a
problem-free but I'm very candid I
really like when I say I don't know it
means I don't know or you know I I don't
because I feel like the reason I have a
job is because I wasn't a bullshitter
I wasn't someone who got on TV and had
talking points or lied to the audience I
really I'm just a regular person and I
want to prove that you can be honest and
normal and real and you know if
something sucks you say that sucks or if
like something shitty you're like or if
you don't know you say I don't know so
I'm sticking with that and you know if I
say I can't talk about something it's
just like a legal issue right that's
rather than that I you know I'm do you
do you see something like the Comey
interview and go like ah I wish I had a
national outlet to get on and spout my
opinion on this are you okay no I mean
I've been doing you know I did Greg
Gutfeld show a couple times and I'm
being very selective like I do have I
could burn in Sam Roberts right exam
hours bunch interviews here I'm picky
though because I I'm used to being in a
host position now so when I'm a guest on
a show I get a little antsy yeah I want
to ask questions I want to jump in there
so it's a little bit of a challenge but
no I I could this sounds terrible for me
you know I don't want to say that it
sounds like very like oh she's think so
she is but no I could I be on TV every
day talking about stuff sure but it's
not I don't want to be part of that
scene
have something really specific that I
want to do next and I can't announce
anything but I'm going somewhere and
then it'll be you'll understand and I'll
be back here to talk about you are going
I am going some can you say at least
give us a timeline yeah when you're
coming back to talk about I can't really
say anything within six years yes it's
it within six years it's within this
year so okay okay I'm going somewhere
and I'll be it'll be really cool and um
yeah but I don't I don't feel the need
to be everywhere all the time I want to
ask you to because you spend a lot of
time at Fox has done more but you've
obviously a different way of being
looked at do you ever have any issues
there with the there's so much stuff
with like Roger Ailes and all these
stuff I'm such as conduct yeah I had no
idea that [ __ ] was happening yeah what
happened to you that's what I'm saying
yes no I want you in something slinky er
even older gay men don't harass me
nobody wants to touch me but did you
ever have any you know I stopped
flirting between people I never saw what
I would call harassment cuz what I saw
was mutual I didn't get harassed I said
this on the view nobody believed me but
Roger and I had Roger was actually the
guy that I would go to if I had an issue
like I would pound down the door and be
like I want to see Roger Ailes and go in
and I think we he and I had an
understanding I remember he made a
comment to me at one point it wasn't
sexual or anything but it was a little
sarcastic and I answered him in my
Brooklyn Italian like wool way yo kind
of thing and he laughed and he was like
you're a tough cookie and we kind of had
that mutual respect of since day one I
didn't have any issue with him I never
got sexually harassed but I'm also the
type of person I don't hang out after
work I don't drink I go in I do my work
I leave I'm like a no-drama girl but no
one bothered me everybody I had a guy I
mean it sounds boring but they had a
great experience do you feel any type of
way when you found out all these people
were getting sexually harassed
no no not at all
I I felt really lucky yeah absolutely
that I dodged you know whatever I feel
bad too because you know people would
say I think a lot of people wanted me to
speak out and I kept saying look this is
terrible if this happened to these women
but I this wasn't my expiry
I didn't have this exhibition I was in
bill shines off as a bunch I was in
Rogers off as a bunch I was in dealing
with male producers all the time I sat
on the set with you know Eric Bolling
and not that nobody real I think I think
I just have an air like I come in and do
my work I leave I'm not interested in
any kind of flirtation and Greg Greg
doesn't foster that kind of environment
at least I dread I like he's not like
that like you know he's funny he's funny
but he's super appropriate he's like you
know and I did a lot of that I did a lie
I think it also depends what shows you
do a lot of you know I did outnumbered
it was all women and then one lucky guy
and but that wasn't that energy I do I
feel there is like a very competitive
energy at Fox it's very like you feel
like who's gonna be in my seat next you
know it's very right that way but I
didn't I didn't that wasn't my
experience what could I say it was a fun
show right I was so much fun I just did
Greg show and I said to him you know
they really shouldn't have gotten rid of
that show that was so that 3 a.m. was
such a great it was a great just let
loose and talk about stuff in a way that
nobody else talks about right and kind
of being appropriate not vulgar but you
know just enough inappropriate to make
every time person that's why they cuz
once Greg was gone Tom salute did a nice
job but then they probably figure
risk/reward there's a bunch of people
that bring comedians on there saying a
lot of like what's the upside people and
audience is starting to get more and
more sensitive right yeah this should
only be a problem for us so what are we
doing you know it's one of those things
we're talking head shows with comics
it's just a problem but Tom honestly
like it's so straightly yes like I feel
I mean I always say to him I'm like Tom
you look like you should be like you
know managing like an ice cream truck in
1955 you know he's got that he's my
friend so I can say that but he's like
so like you know just peachy clean I
feel like if anybody could do a show
like I would not be comfortable I mean I
worked with Sherrod so you know and I
love him but you never know what you
when you meet Tom and you find out he
does like barbershop quartet you're like
yeah right I could see you doing
barbershop quartet what does Andy levy
doing
Andy's at CNN oh he is yeah he works
with se on you know I see us rehearse
yes he has that HLN show and he's at HLN
doing I think he's like kind of like I
don't know if sidekick is like an
inappropriate word or whatever but he's
like her you know right-hand man right
so that's what they're doing I haven't
yeah I know I haven't really been in
touch with me he don't an see nice to
live in the same building
really yeah the same building I used to
see him all the time so to me and Greg
actually really yeah I don't think I
knew him back then I think you told me
that years later okay though we live in
this era with me him and Bob Kelly in
the same building oh wow I know there's
a real drop off after Greg and what are
you promoting obviously on Twitter could
this long as we have one minute left
with you Jedidiah be libelous aim
Instagram at Jedediah bila book comes
out October 9th I can't talk about it
yet it's life-changing
it's like you're gonna do you gonna look
at your whole life differently I'm not
even kidding and I'm going to the Emmys
the Daytime Emmys in a few weeks
hopefully I win
are you nominated I'm nominated for a
host for the view Oh wouldn't it be
great if I come in next time yeah me
gonna every time you see me from here on
and I'm gonna have the Emmy of five wins
easily is it a group nomination host
yeah it's for all of us and Meghan's
included cuz she's on the show this year
shove it right down their throat so
she's in the group I don't know she was
I don't watch you get along with Meghan
I don't know where that well but I have
in the past yeah I mean I don't I worked
with her a little bit at Fox and we've
had some exchanges I remember once
asking her for like a referral for a
makeup artist in LA and she's always
been really nice to me yeah yeah she's a
really sweet guy like I wish